president Trump is criticizing former
President Obama for not acting sooner
when he learned that Vladimir Putin
ordered hackers to help the Trump
campaign report says the CIA first told
mr. Obama about the Russian president's
order back in August now that's about
the same time that mr. Trump claimed the
election would be rigged in favor of
Hillary Clinton on Saturday President
Trump tweeted this since the Obama
administration was told way before the
2016 election that Russians were
meddling why no action focus on them not
T which stands for trump chip Reid is at
the White House with the latest on this
story chip good morning
well good morning up to this point
President Trump has been reluctant even
to acknowledge that the Russians
interfered in the 2016 election but now
that he has someone else to blame it's
become a major talking point I just
heard today for the first time that
Obama knew about Russia a long time
before the election and he did nothing
about it in an interview President Trump
attacked his predecessor for allowing
Russian meddling in the election to go
unanswered question is if he had the
information why didn't he do something
about he should have done something
about it
the Washington Post reported Friday that
the Obama administration knew the
Russian government was interfering in
the election in August of last year but
didn't make it public until October 7th
they also had intelligence confirming
that the Russian goal was to defeat
Hillary Clinton given the seriousness of
this I think the administration need to
call out Russia earlier the top Democrat
on the House Intelligence Committee Adam
Schiff usually a critic of mr. Trump
echoed his charge think the Obama
administration should have done a lot
more when it became clear that not only
was Russia intervening but it was big
directed at the highest levels of the
Kremlin former President Obama's
spokesman Eric Schultz said the
situation was taken extremely seriously
as is evident by his raising of the
issue directly with President Putin the
Obama administration also shut down two
Russian government compounds and ejected
35 Russian diplomats in late December
Russia is not our ally Russia is not our
friend
West Virginia Democrat Joe Manchin said
both a public admission and a response
should have been more Swift what was
known back in August and once it was
verified
and cross-check should have been made
public it should have made made public
okay that wasn't done former Obama
administration officials say they did
not act sooner because they did not want
to appear to be interfering in the
election on the side of Hillary Clinton
charlie thanks chip